lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
because it's chill
i think the answer is because it's cho
that's not worst defendant what is it's
cause it's chill it's chill
your honor
are we going
we already started
we already started right
this is [ __ ] gold ship no it's just
all right well don't
sing wc dub c
you can't do the rest of that i know
that um
yeah dude we're here lifeline episode
something brought to you by super cult
so i do know though no but brought to
you by do you know that brought to you
by yeah i remember it what i said last
episode i didn't really remember what
that was oh you remember it brought to
you by
who did that though it was the the thing
brought to you by it wasn't everybody it
was yes yes thank you thank you i know
that it took us to [ __ ] took us to
class so hard so yes when he when he
said espn he leaned back in his chair
and put his feet up yeah
rocked us so hard so uh
i hope my son doesn't grow up to be a
serial killer do you know what i mean i
yeah if you want to talk about that go
okay yeah because we wanted to do the
episode at 2 p.m
you did it i did i did we by we i mean
me and i said it was fun because i'm the
kind of guy that does
kind of goes with it just you you roll
with me i roll with it just in general
right and i said let's do it at two and
we're recording on a saturday and chris
over here our producer says
you know what i you know i don't want to
be like i'm just i'm sure it's fine you
know it's cool if we need to but like
you know it's saturday and i want to do
my day can we do it at 11. and i said
okay that's cool but i just wanted to
play with my son before uh i he went
down for a nap and i wanted to shoot
during my nap but it's okay and he said
uh you know and i said okay i'm okay
with two o'clock or whatever just i
really want to be there for my son
because you know i don't want to not be
there for him because dads who aren't
there you should have to do this
you interrupted we said yeah we have to
do it dude yeah you said i said i can do
whatever i can do it at two i prefer to
not have my nephew turn into a serial
killer but whatever because most kids
that don't have most kids that don't
have their parents around they turn out
more likely to become serial killers or
terrible people in some other way
criminal in one way or another so i said
oh [ __ ] well that's fine it shouldn't be
a big deal my son maybe grow up to be a
soldier he's just a little bit more
likely to be and that's fine and we'll
tell that to the families if he ends up
getting that that oh the producer of the
podcast don't worry that your family is
that somebody died in your family
because my producer wanted to go sailing
yeah right right right later that
saturday yeah so don't even worry about
it and then they're gonna feel better
right they'll feel a little bit better
uh so don't even worry about it about
their dead relatives right so it's fine
so good so we figured that out um so
we're here so we're here here or
whatever it is we figured that out yeah
so now that that's all settled yeah so
uh and and i drove over here and let me
just tell you man i was excited to come
over here because it's saturday mm-hmm
and i knew that it was going to be
smooth sailing right because people
aren't going to work and stuff right
and dude the traffic was just gorgeous
it was just gorgeous man the traffic was
just insanely gorgeous the traffic was
[ __ ] gorgeous [ __ ] it was [ __ ]
gorgeous but why [ __ ] but why was the
traffic so gorgeous on a saturday right
i know why why
because we were coming on downtown and
downtown is where people
show up in in in numbers to get angry
about one thing or another and people
are always angry and on the weekends is
when people have time off so that's when
they plan them so they're coming down to
do protests and stuff i saw people
protesting correct um they should pro
you know they should protest traffic
that's what they should protest no more
traffic stay home that's what it should
be i'm going to be in my apartment
silently protesting
no traffic protesting traffic
i help
i don't think anything but it was
gorgeous man it was so gorgeous i was
driving and people were bumper to bumper
and i was just like god this is gorgeous
and then
pharaoh
and then and then two and then
motorcycles row by me quickly and it was
very loud and rumbly and i hate that and
it was just gorgeous man of course it
was gorgeous too in my ears it was
gorgeous it was gorgeous for my eyes and
i you know it was great because i had to
keep hitting the break and then go a
little bit and hit the break and it was
and you know what it was dude it was
gorgeous every one of those two minutes
absolutely every one of those too many
minutes was just absolutely exquisitely
gorgeous conference so i love
so i love that traffic man i just love
that it's there and i love that it hit
me by surprise because it's saturday and
you love how gorgeous it was just
absolutely gorgeous i was driving down
here and i was just like is this a
painting by georgia o'keeffe wow because
it's the only artist he knows only
artists does this look like you know
what i was like driving down i was like
is this a [ __ ] painting of a flower
that looks like a [ __ ] by jordan
because this is just absolutely gorgeous
right right yeah and so i finally got
here and i'm pissed right and that's
great dude and we're here late anyway so
the so chris can't even go [ __ ]
sailing and now i'm [ __ ] way
not with my son for even longer because
of the gorgeous traffic and that's great
so my son's a serial killer and the
producers don't even get to do it
oh yeah okay good could
anybody have come in hotter than you've
come in with this
is that even possible
and thanks so much for the gorgeous
traffic okay thank you that's what it
was dude thanks la for the gorgeous
traffic so uh but i'm thrilled about it
so that's great great
okay well that's that's being defensive
i'm just no i think you're being very
angry and trying to cover it up with
with words that imply you're not angry
so many words for defensive nope that's
not defensive
this is a different
groups of wording group of wordings okay
my son said
i left today and my son said i said
um
[Music]
i'll see you later and he says
and i said i love you and he said i love
you
and then he said i'll be serial killing
in 20 years i hope i hope i hope you
enjoy i hope you enjoy i hope tell chris
i
the producer i hope you enjoy sailing
because that's three people that are
gonna wind up dead
in 25 years
um all right so yeah so that's what's up
that's cool but other than that man just
been you look great you look good oh
just rethought great
you look good you look good that's so
[ __ ] rude
uh
i think you were going to say great what
what made you downgrade it too cause
you're doing a you have a comb over and
you don't need a crown well some the
thing about my hair is that any which
way it goes it looks kind of flowing and
great you don't have to have a combo
that there you go absolutely amazing
well way better
great now great it looked amazing before
as well great just just to clear that up
for you kristin said my hair looks great
yesterday so
yesterday what about today i didn't
really i i mean we saw each other
briefly but
because i had to leave you you know why
she didn't rush out because we had to do
it so earlier it's gorgeous you know why
she's what because it's so rare for you
no yeah maybe no dude also i got [ __ ]
tan a little bit yeah that's the first
time you've ever [ __ ] you know i got
tan dude this is how white i am dude
okay this is how white i am so you know
i got married i was in
the uh ceremony or the wedding oh i hope
so yeah and i was in there i was in that
because it's for me and it was at 5 30
outside i was outside for [ __ ] 25
minutes and i burned to a crisp at 5 30.
that's how white i am the next day i
woke up and i was a [ __ ] lobster dude
yeah you were burnt yeah yeah and so now
what it turned into some color so dude i
look great so i was sitting there all
tan in gorgeous traffic and it's fine
you do look better with a little bit of
attention i know i got i got to but you
know what laying out in the sun you know
what it is it's boring you can't look at
your phone because it's too bright you
start sweating and you can't read a book
it's too bright you can read a book it's
too bright no i don't agree we can
listen to a [ __ ] podcast you can read
a book you can listen to a podcast and
also be like doing doper [ __ ] though
like what i wish being in the sun was
more fun this is what i think that you
should be this is what i think should
happen if you sit in the sun because
being in the sun is healthy right i mean
to a degree to a degree right to not i
mean not you're not going to [ __ ]
want to be out there all the time and
just like with you
with no protection but to a degree it's
nice so here's what the lord should do
when you're out in the sun chilling you
should get to jizz
just chilling not even touching anything
sexual
you should just it sh you should be have
a low-grade jizz
like this it's a steady stream like a
low-grade edging no the problem the
problem with that is no one would ever
get out of the sun
so the lord should not do that but it
only works but it only works for like 30
minutes and then you and then it stops
right and you bust you know what you
know what that made me think of that a
lot of things make me think of when i
was a kid i read michael crichton's
terminal man yeah and there's a passage
in the book about it's like about how
the brain is manipulated yeah through
like putting nodes on it and you can
like let the person in an experiment tap
the certain buttons that
connect to certain parts of the brain
yeah and there's a part in the book
early on it's just a really short part
but i think about all the time where a
guy was allowed to give an access to a
button yeah that helped him jizz that
that set off an orgasm in his brain not
in on his body but in his brain and he
turned into like a drooling
[ __ ] up like massive bone and skin who
was like unable to do anything except
like [ __ ] hit that button
uh yeah but he didn't have he didn't
jizz
he was just a brain yeah he just kept
yeah yeah yeah
so that's that's what that's the level
of uh [ __ ] we're talking about here so i
don't think the lord as you put it the
lord should do that [ __ ] terrifying
it's scary that's why it stuck with me i
was like 12 and i was like yeah well
also what's [ __ ] 12 reading the
terminal no you shouldn't you definitely
shouldn't yeah but i did that yeah yeah
[ __ ] 11 years old reading the
andromeda strain oh yeah i think it was
the intro media string
all right so uh all right well dude
that's that's probably why you [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] up right i read jurassic
park i read congo i read [ __ ] and
android media strain did you read them
in drama stream yeah i mean terminal man
i read congo
that's it you only read i read congo
yeah and i read jurassic park
the same idiot i know
and
again tim curry in congo the same
idiographics over and over again that
character is legendary what i realized i
looked up tim curry and congo and so
many people have pulled clips and put
that [ __ ] up on youtube really yeah it's
like a famous thing yeah wow i mean it
was to us when we were young but wow i
didn't realize it was to the world how
[ __ ] amazing would he be at a dinner
party you know what i mean you were just
like you everyone had some talking like
shut the [ __ ] up dude tim curry's here
yeah tim curry has done some of the
greatest [ __ ] ever on screen so yeah
yeah me too so um all right so
so let's do uh let's do let's get into
it you know what let's get into it let's
do
hi i'm matt hi chris
um one week ago i went to the swimming
pool to meet my uh friend
uh when i arrived a little bit earlier
and i was in cubicle getting changed and
i could hear my uh friend in the next
cubicle on a telephone call
and it's kind of a lot of agreeing a lot
of mm-hmm
all that kind of noise
um and then about 10 15 seconds later i
hear and say
that was the best [ __ ] i've ever had
so i was
going
like
jesus
and then five seconds after that i hear
another guy say
that's no problem
oh wow so i stayed in that cubicle and i
waited until the normal time should have
met him so it's like nothing strange
right but i wanted to ask
would you tell the friend that you heard
that situation or would you just let it
go and wait for him to tell you either
way who cares you know the heart wants
what the heart wants
but i just wanted to ask for
your opinion thanks very much guys have
a nice day bye
it's so funny that you have to say
at the end like it doesn't matter i'm
cool with whatever which is cool yeah of
course it is but you do need to say that
i think though actually i know but it's
funny that you have to right because
it's like you don't want him he doesn't
want to come off as being like [ __ ] i
think it's not funny because it makes
you think of all the people that
wouldn't be okay with it and then that
makes me want to cry so it's a deeper
like you know what you know
you read all those [ __ ] up books when
you were tweeting maybe so maybe uh it's
deeper i'm a sensitive guy i'm in touch
with the universe i'm in touch with
michael creighton books when i was 11.
so um so i read so much john grisham
when i was 10. so um
so
uh
so the guy got sucked off okay he was at
the pool am i getting that right he was
at the pool the guy didn't know he got
sucked off and the [ __ ] friend was
right next to him in his [ __ ] uh
odd future hat now the guy got sucked
off and that's fine but this is what you
do when that happens bro okay you go
like this
received
information received
he's sealing an envelope he's putting it
somewhere he's putting it in his shirt
pocket and he's leaving it there and
you keep it you keep it for rainy days
it's just there oh what are you a
[ __ ] villain you're gonna no no
you're not a villain but what if the
guy's a villain you have to keep the
[ __ ]
wow dude what if the guy's a villain
dude you got to look out for yourself
dude okay well here's here's what i
would do but the topic was gorgeous but
what i would do is
what i would do first of all is this man
your friend is he in the closet or is he
or he was in the bathroom
no but is he if it depends on if he's in
the closet he's in the closet he doesn't
know okay so let's say he's in the
closet then i think bringing it up with
him is an absolute no no because why
why
why like push that why why even poke
that bear there's no reason to
uh but if you if you if he is
gay or if he's openly even bisexual
absolutely bring it up and [ __ ] make
fun of him for you
god damn hilarious so he got sucked off
in a [ __ ] wet bathroom huh yeah yeah
so what made you so what made you think
i wouldn't hear that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so why did you think that i
wouldn't know that yeah but uh if he's
in the closet dude
yeah that's that's sensitive [ __ ] i
wouldn't yeah i wouldn't kick that
hornet's nasty uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh but also save it for a rainy day
right so basically what you're saying is
safe for rainy day so we agree same
amount i think i i that that is so
[ __ ] funny though dude oh yeah i
would love to see that guy his eyes
slowly each time something happened get
bigger and bigger be like yeah yeah his
eyes popping out of his [ __ ] head
he's [ __ ] my favorite part was when
he was thinking well thinking like wow
that's some phone call right right right
mm-hmm
just like god wow he must be getting a
return
back that he didn't think he was at
amazon or something the greatest news of
all time yes it's a huge rebate yeah oh
[ __ ] this rebate
oh this calm rebate
it's so funny oh my god rebate in your
mouth
oh hell yeah swallowed that rebate such
a bad disguise you know
so poorly covering up what's oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] grab under there with that rebate
can't think of another word
to cover for it i mean yeah that's right
that's right and save it for rainy day
you never know when you might need it i
don't know about that but i guess
technically you are saving it for any
day if you're not telling me exactly
there we go yeah yeah so that's let's
keep it hilarious though and please
never forget that story because that is
[ __ ] well we won't it's now
immortalized yeah i never will on
lifeline all right what we got
hey chris hemanha is doing it it's a
[ __ ] um i need you guys um
advice something's up something's afoot
my roommate
who's also my cousin
oh uh i love the death
uh oh you know this but he's a
conspiracy theorist oh [ __ ]
and
i don't know what to say when he tells
me things and i don't know what to say
when he asks me things
because
politics
piece [ __ ]
and i don't like that [ __ ] so
i don't know i don't like to be involved
and
i need advice to
you know i don't know because like
things you saying like i don't know if i
even you know believe you because like
yeah you know
wow
i think sometimes it's good for these
people especially if you aren't
interested in politics and don't
actually know how to debunk the person
because that's let's face it not gonna
do anything anyway
ask him to if
if you have the tolerance for it ask him
to prove it
and say i don't know about this stuff
show me what you're talking about
because what you're explaining sounds
[ __ ]
wild don't say crazy say wild
um it sounds gorgeous
oftentimes when you do that that person
will show you something that is
the opposite of proof yeah they're just
like the clouds it'll be like a meme
some person made with jfk's face on it
and say like something about the cia on
top and then something about everyday
life on the bottom you know and just
like that's proof of what
proof of what they're like look trash
can paul posted this yeah exactly yeah
dude dude look at his account you know
what it's two thousand followers it's a
picture of christian bale smiling right
yeah exactly yeah saying biden is a
lizard right or the other thing you can
do is just if you just want to disengage
and have him stop
just just say you believe him just be
like oh
oh oh [ __ ] all the time yeah and just
let him really yeah jfk is that guy yeah
right yeah oh my god jfk junior's alive
and that's him yeah dude i don't i i
don't understand what it is about
conspiracy theorist people that they
they like
why do they have to always be convincing
you of [ __ ] it's like the new religion
it's like i don't give a [ __ ] okay so
you believe that that's [ __ ] cool i
don't even give a [ __ ] dude i like
weirdos i like if you think joe biden is
a lizard that's [ __ ] awesome well but
stop talking about it so [ __ ] much to
me and don't make me try and think it i
don't give a [ __ ] that's all part of it
though that's part of the appeal they're
in the secret the group of secret
knowledge that kabob possesses the
secret knowledge and it's part of why
it's appealing to them and
furthermore what appeals to them even
more is getting other people to
think about what they're saying and to
actually come on board with their [ __ ]
do you think if they knew it was true
they wouldn't try and spread the
information
or is it like a super saiyan secure
thing where they're just like i gotta
get people to [ __ ] it's like dude
mormons secretly no come on dude i think
a lot of this [ __ ] i think a lot of it
is true is actual some kind of at least
adjacent to mental illness yeah yeah
yeah yeah so i don't know i i don't know
what the [ __ ] going on in their minds
in fact i've thought about it and read
about it so much because it fascinates
the [ __ ] out of me there's almost never
any convincing it's like an addict like
you don't convince an addict to stop
taking the thing that they're taking
that's ruining their lives
they just are gonna do it until they're
ready to not do it and a conspiracy
theorist is either gonna just change and
come to realize it
but they're rarely rarely rarely gonna
ever be
sh have proof shown that is gonna make
them change their [ __ ] mind which
this guy can't even do anyway because he
doesn't like politics
wow yeah
um
wow
i wish i knew what kind of conspiracy
theories this guy's talking about that's
the thing about conspiracy theorists
that they don't just believe in one of
them yeah they all believe in all of
them which makes them suspect even more
yeah yeah of course they're like dude
joe biden's a lizard it was a cup this
was a cover-up that happened we didn't
land on the moon right [ __ ] all this
other [ __ ] the earth is flat yeah the
earth is flat bill gates is injecting us
with hiv whatever the [ __ ] it is you
know what i mean yep 3g 5g 5g [ __ ] yeah
yeah um
and uh i believe in all of it dude
i believe in all of it well i imagine
how stressed [ __ ] out you would be if
you believed in all of it well i think
that's another part of the allure you
get to be stressed out about [ __ ] that
is way out of your control instead of
being stressed out about paying your
bills
it's more exciting i do that with my ocd
yes dude [ __ ] yeah dude i turned the
lights on and off a million times
because i can't deal with my anxiety
dude amazing dude
amazing dude
well it's similar though it's yeah it is
similar yeah yeah okay cool well made me
sad yeah there we go okay
next one bro yeah
hi chris and matt
so a few years ago my husband and i
bought our first house in the midwest it
happened to have a pool in the backyard
we also have neighbors who next door
have you know two sons they're 14 18
somewhere around there and ever since we
moved in every summer they always have
asked us if they can come to swim in our
pool
um and so you know we don't have a
relationship with these people other
than you know waving to them when
they're mowing the lawn and
you know to give you a specific example
one day it was the hottest day of the
year and we can see them over there
nobody's going on they're
trimming trees and just absolutely
drenched in sweat and we get a text from
the mom and it's one it's the younger
son asking us you know can me my dad and
my brother come swim in your pool
and so we just don't respond because
yeah good
no
and then because we didn't respond they
come and knock on our door and ask us
again you know if they can swim in our
pool and this happens all the time and
so we have summer season coming up and
so you know we really need to know do we
need to move how do we respond to this
once and for all please help me
that's a brutal one dude that is a
brutal one so
[ __ ]
uh that's just that's bad like that
hurts my heart like what a [ __ ] whole
situation yeah
you gotta just you gotta just be
together when you answer the door next
time and say
we're just this is not a public pool
we're we're we're not really
ready or we don't feel right having
other people just come over to our
[ __ ] property whenever they [ __ ]
want
you say yeah but you have to sleep in
our beds and also eat all of our food
and they probably won't even get the
pictures you have to pay our bills you
know what you have to you know wow
that's so [ __ ] [ __ ] up this is
gonna be on fear thy neighbor someone's
winding up dead this is how fear the
neighbor starts i know i bring this up a
lot yeah i hate
i hate people like this
this father is raising such little
pieces of [ __ ] to think that this is
okay to [ __ ] do yeah this is a
[ __ ] nightmare person yeah jeez it is
but also
uh the the thing about this is
just say
oh you know what happened dude and i
would do this if i was the husband i
would i would go out there and i would
say
this is so embarrassing
i [ __ ] in the pool and it's got we have
to drain it and then have it come back
and then every time they ask say the
same thing yeah i [ __ ] in it again you
could definitely do that yeah yeah and
then they would stop asking it'd be like
are you do they keep [ __ ] in the break i
don't give a [ __ ] dude that's a that's
actually that'd be amazing if you want
to because here's why dude then you get
to have them not be in your pool yeah
and have a little bit of fun with it
yeah yeah have a little bit of fun with
it dude this is the thing they're trying
to mess up your day
every situation even if it's bad can be
good dude take a problem add another
problem and then it's better right
so just like i think [ __ ] like that's
my [ __ ] dude i mean if you want to
battle crazy with crazy then definitely
do that yeah if you want it just to stop
entirely
both answer the door
have it be both of you and both of you
say
one and then the other can speak
whatever
units in the united front like this is
not something we're comfortable with
moreover it's not something we even want
so like we're not gonna allow you guys
to use our pool you know i would say we
don't even really know you dude yeah
you're just neighbor you just happen to
be near us yes exactly so don't be in my
pool bro that's so insane wow dude she
could even say just like i wouldn't let
like some random stranger from the next
town over right in my pool i wouldn't
let you swim in my pool we don't know
you and even if we did
we don't want someone in and out of our
property whenever they want
i have a little bit fun with it dude
this is an opportunity you got to have
fun with it they're creating stress for
you yeah deal with it the way you want
to in the most fun way to be the husband
and say the better you know because a
woman does it because they would believe
you i [ __ ] in the pool i'm sorry and i
keep sitting in the pool i don't know
what's going on with me man i gotta go
to therapy every time i get in i just
[ __ ] yeah dude it actually sucks but
sell it be like it really really really
is terrible every time i one time i
walked by and i just wanted to see if it
was warm so i put my finger in it and
immediately i [ __ ] my pants
like it's something was weird about me
in the right [ __ ] that would work but
also what if they're like oh we don't
mind that's
that's i'd be like i mind it's my [ __ ] i
don't want to get you sick
lawsuit right yeah i mean yeah yeah yeah
oh
horrible dude did you ever have a
situation like this where's something
that is not that that is extreme no
that's a that's a crazy level of
remember the one time audacity remember
the one time i was going i i invited you
well after a set i invited you to the
[ __ ] diner to go eat and we were
gonna meet up and then i know i drove a
door guy home from the comedy store and
and i was and he was like oh man thanks
for the ride home because he was gonna
have to [ __ ] walk or take the bus
yeah i was like dude and i was like yeah
i'm actually going to [ __ ] it's all
good i was going this way anyway to meet
my brother go eat and he was like oh
dude i would i'll i'll come man mistake
yeah i would love to come i'll take on
your part yeah now but but
in my defense dude i was like
well who the i mean i didn't think this
was a possibility dude you don't i
didn't even know the guy she should have
thought about it and i had texted text i
was like matt i don't know what to do
this guy came
you know what you should have said oh
[ __ ] it's gonna text my brother canceled
i'm just gonna go home i'll drop you off
and then i'd go yeah and then he would
have [ __ ] went anyway
we could just go
and then show up i show up and you're
there and we're i'm just like
and he's just like
you know you text me pretend we're not
brothers and [ __ ] yeah you have to get
out of it who's that guy that looks like
you
oh my god dude yeah whatever happened to
that guy i don't even know where he is
that's that's he was wearing a chicago
cubs out i remember that he was in
chicago so from chicago all right cool
only guy from chicago would do that so
all right cool
next
what's up chris what's up matt what's
going on
he's going through some hard times thank
you
my advice that i need is i need i need
to know like how to head so much go and
approach women like i need advice on
that like whether it's if i'm out or
wherever you know like how do i go if i
if i think to myself oh you know she's
pretty like how do i go and talk to them
like i find that like i don't know just
like awkward so that and i don't know
how to just start a conversation so yeah
just let me know thank you shout out
that's a patreon subscriber dude uh
for uh my podcast uh
it's tough because it's completely
scenario dependent sometimes the
scenario just doesn't allow a situation
for you to do it sometimes it's just
the situation you can't
come up with a good scenario on how to
approach someone and you kind of leave
it at that because the last thing you
want to do is actually encroach on
someone's
life or time or in their space you know
it's like there are a few scenarios
where that's just it's not possible so
in those scenarios forgive yourself for
not being able to do it but uh
in times where it's like a setting where
that is sort of
i don't want to say allowed because it's
allowed everywhere but like when it's
when it's more sort of common to
approach people who are strangers or
whatever um i think it's totally
scenario dependent like where you are
what time it is
who you're with who they're with like
and i think it needs to be
as organic as possible but i think maybe
what you're struggling with is
it's it's not there is no answer of how
to do it there's only an answer of
you you have to do it because like
there's no how-to there's just like when
it arises you're either going to live
with regret for not doing it oh man or
do it and and potentially fail yeah what
you're dealing with is the potential of
failure and what you got to realize is
that is kind of minuscule compared to
regret dude failing is nothing regret is
is everything i think john lennon said
that you know what dude it's like are
you gonna die you're gonna die bro just
go back to your thing you're gonna die
bro just [ __ ] go out there and do it
well you want to have a family right you
want to grow i mean maybe you don't
maybe you just want to get laid do the
horizontal mambo but bro you got to
[ __ ] get out there and do this this
is why you're here on this earth is to
keep the species moving and you're just
sitting back bro you're just sitting
back letting a girl walk by outside of a
cafe and you're just sitting there
drinking that hot coffee like oh i wish
i could bro this is your life man you
wear that sweater that says life rips
make it rip [ __ ] you gotta say
hey and guess what you might it's not
that you might fail you're gonna you're
gonna fail you're gonna fail and guess
what you're gonna fail again and again
and again and again and then pretty soon
you're you're not going to fail
eventually you're not going to fail and
it's going to lead to laying down
horizontally and it's going to lead to
splurting and it's going to lead to nine
months down the line and you're going to
have a baby and then it's going to lead
to having a family and then those kids
are going to grow up and you're going to
be able to tell them life ripped for me
man and i went out there while i was
drinking my hot coffee and your mom
walked by and i was insecure but finally
it worked you know i hit on so many
girls and none of them wanted me and the
only one that accepted me was your mom
okay and i guess maybe that makes her a
loser but it doesn't matter because
we're losers take care yeah you should
have stopped halfway through but the one
thing i would say and then when i laid
down horizontally with your mom and
split it in or you came out
maybe he just wants an actual companion
he's not thinking about splurting just
yet i guess but the big thing is
whatever you're seeking just
do
the rest of us guys and all women a
[ __ ] favor and just don't be a
[ __ ] gross creep yeah yeah yeah don't
be a [ __ ] gross creep when you do it
right don't ever be in a scenario where
you could leave it and the girl or woman
leaves thinking oh my god that guy was
such a [ __ ] creep but sometimes
you're not in control of that you think
conversations are going to go a certain
way and then you say something [ __ ] up
by mistake or whatever the [ __ ] and then
they come away with a different
experience it's two people bro well
there i guess there's a dry area
there's also a completely obvious area
of creepdem that you should never ever
ever [ __ ] enter it sucks nobody likes
it it's a [ __ ]
absolute lie that the kind of guy who's
like
cat calling or being a [ __ ] creep
ever ever ever gets the result yeah he's
looking for yeah it's just not [ __ ]
true and nobody wants it yeah it's bad
women hate it and it's bad for other
[ __ ] men because it makes them look
bad right it's mostly just old white
construction workers and also young
puerto ricans that do that but yeah um
uh yeah dude catcalling is crazy but
just be like hey what's up
you got you know what i mean like you
got kids remember i knew this girl
once i knew that this chick told me that
that was the best line the way the guy
hit on her she said i said she said the
best way a guy ever hit on me he came up
he said you got kids really yeah i'm
confused why is that good because she
thought it was so funny and then they
started talking i mean she never went
out with him but he got married
no yeah i know
and that man was me no and uh no it's
but the thing there's no right
line or phrase or topic it's just
situation dependent but the thing to
keep in mind is the things not to do
don't go away with regret and don't be a
[ __ ] creep it's better to be rejected
than live with regret
rejection is nothing you'll forget about
it by [ __ ] dinner time it doesn't
matter also different people are
different you know like one time i heard
on a i was watching a tv show and this
this woman was saying like they were
talking it was like i don't know what
the hell i was watching but they were
asking different women what the best way
to hit on them was and one woman said
like it's best honestly if they just
come up to me and say you want to [ __ ]
oh my god yeah i know and that is 99 of
women would find that [ __ ] appalling
my point is there's people out there
that like all sorts of different things
right
um that's true yeah i think the main
thing is
be comfortable in your own skin
right the second you're trying something
yeah or
you know what i mean like yeah
be naturally you as naturally you as you
can possibly be
uh but yeah the the there's there's
nothing worse than living with regret uh
and there's really a lot of things that
are way worse than being rejected being
rejected is nothing
it it really is nothing especially if
you get used to it yeah it's nothing
yeah
been rejected so much
yeah me yeah yeah me too yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure yeah it's it's hard for
everyone is there like a single
one thing that you could do every time
if you're like i don't know what to say
right oh yeah like 100 percent let's say
it's having your number on a piece of
paper right yeah like you dropped this
yeah yeah which is stupid right
but it could work
if you have nothing else like maybe
that's
what i like to do that's what i want i
like to do this you're at a cafe and you
go and you're going to pay there's a hot
chicken line you go into paint you go
like this you go like this uh yeah and
then it's your turn you say i would like
an american oh oh [ __ ] dude and you just
drop a bunch of [ __ ] cash so you go
like this i'm [ __ ] my bad my bad my
my bad my bad dude i don't with some of
this yours and then be like it doesn't
matter to me
go to an atm before you go yeah yeah you
have to get back and pretend you're
fumbling with your money make sure it's
not outside because it could blow away
yeah make sure it's not just like 36
dollars you got to get like most of the
money in your account yeah yeah yeah and
then just right when you're done go back
to the bank and put it all back because
you don't want to carry that much cash
because it's hard no i mean yeah i guess
that's i guess that's possible if the
one thing if
i just think it's tough to to to have a
once so to speak one-size-fits-all
thing that you do because i think that
it
limits your
your 14 stop i'm sorry dude it limits
your [ __ ] ability to even get the
result that you want i think because
it's like further narrowing the pass for
you to get through yeah
i remember one time i remember one time
i was
i would see this girl at this coffee
shop
and i would and she was so hot i mean
this was [ __ ]
god when was this this was probably
[ __ ] 13 years ago
and i was like
we gotta hang out sometime you know and
she was like uh yeah i don't know i have
a boyfriend i was like oh [ __ ] well when
you guys gonna break up like just a
[ __ ] idiot you know and then i would
see her and then one time i was like
she said she broke up and i was like oh
let me get your number and she was like
sure yeah fine here and she gave me her
number and then i
i
wrote it
i wrote or i wrote it down or put in my
phone and then when i walked away i
looked at the number because i was gonna
text her something and i was like it was
so obviously a fake number oh that i was
like oh
this girl actually just wants me to not
talk to her yeah and i was like
wow
and i just like i felt kind of bad
no you're not so bad you was like eight
one eight five two five two five two
five two five two like literally
but you don't have to feel bad you just
take that inside and realize that she
doesn't like me but it's a [ __ ] i know
no i felt bad though because for the
past yeah yeah and like like it's so
annoying for for like that's just
something that's annoying that look it
sucks that guys have to do this and hit
on women like to make them to like to to
like
to to instigate
yeah right yeah mostly that's initiate a
dude thing right but like
but like it's an it it sucks that girls
have to deal with [ __ ] like it [ __ ]
sucks that a girl if she just wants to
go have a brunch with her friend she's
got if she's hot or even if she's not
she's got to deal with some dude that's
like oh
my [ __ ] sister
has that same jacket and you're like oh
yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah it's
so annoying dude yeah it's a little bit
like being [ __ ] like it happens to me
like on the on the on the level of
people are like like i was at the coffee
bean and television you know how i
[ __ ] freak with the coffee bean tea
leaf i do know that and uh and uh this
girl just immediately i'm sitting there
she's like crystalia and then everyone's
just like
and i'm just like
you know so it's like but to be a
[ __ ] it's good how you made it about
yourself well but bro you got to bring
your own experience to the situation
right but to be a 10
bro to be a 10 to be a [ __ ] 10 like
when you walk you're you know what i
mean like you're you know what i mean
you're right you're i don't like but
your titties move
if you're a 10 and you're walking and
your titties are moving the opposite
direction as you bounce like this
you're describing jessica rabbit
like you're just taking steps you're
walking into just somewhere just to the
dmv and all you want to do is get your
[ __ ] picture taken right because your
your license is uh expired and you don't
even know because you're a hot chick and
you have to deal with that [ __ ] and
you're walking and you're taking steps
and as you take a down step your lumps
go up to the left dude dudes are gonna
be like hey my sister has that same
jacket dude's going to be like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with that woman
that's not good i'm just saying you're
taking a [ __ ] step on the downswing
to the bottom right and your titties are
[ __ ] activating to the upper left
some dude is gonna be like my sister has
that same jacket it's annoying as [ __ ]
for these tens okay but also non tens
every woman every woman deals with this
out in the [ __ ] world
it's like it doesn't matter like a lot
of men are afraid of like supremely
beautiful women and they don't even get
talked to at all i know dude i know i
understand that and that's another thing
that they have to wear you got to walk
worry about this [ __ ] the other 10
there's a super duper 10 like in an
almost eleven and when she [ __ ] takes
the down step to the bottom oh my gosh
go [ __ ] above her shoulders do it and
it's insane and she's like why do no
guys ever talk to me and [ __ ] are
around her dude dude [ __ ] men can be
[ __ ] too and they're just like i wish
i could uh i want to say that her uh my
sister has the same jacket but she's
like i guess i'll leave and a [ __ ]
dude 10 is like i want to tell her that
my sister has the same jacket and she
spins around and walks away and [ __ ]
takes the down step to the bottom right
and her titties go up above to the upper
left and it's like dude they're missing
out they could be doing the horizontal
mambo they could be splurting and a
[ __ ] kid could come out nine months
later my take away from that is that
there are so many sisters with the same
jacket
so many sisters have the jacket that
this woman's wearing all i'm saying is
dude everybody wants to find someone
right and that's actually not all you're
saying and if you're a
a chick that is taking steps and as your
ticket steps your titties are moving in
the opposite directions
dude go to the doctor go straight to the
[ __ ] doctor that's not true bro when
you see you know what i'm talking about
when you see
all right well what the [ __ ] are you
talking about cartoons no like [ __ ]
you know
hefty breasted women like when you i'm
saying half do you have to six sack
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh i'm sweating
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] mouth mouth you know what i
mean
no dude all right dude no a lot of the
time i don't know what's inside jimbo
okay
dude my friend
my friend when i was in high school
and he [ __ ] said and he was like oh
man it was his chick named stacey
stacy you know no one real his name's
stacy what her name was stacy dude and
she [ __ ] and my buddy thought she was
so hot
wow and he was like oh man when she
watched my jimbo and i was like jim
and he said yeah dude jugs in my mouth
she can't even say it
hey [ __ ] jugs in my mouth baby oh
so there's two bees
two m's two m's yeah uh can't spell
jacksonville baby oh bro i never forget
we were on the [ __ ] we were walking
up the stairs bro
he was so loud i have a question it was
echoey because it was the stairwell and
he was like drugs in my mouth baby
i have a question though did he make
that up or is that something no he made
it up bro wow
that's so ludicrous
that's so ludicrous that you actually
can say that out loud because what the
[ __ ] no one knows jimbo yeah
that's
how old is he like 15 16. we were in
high school yeah so young yeah oh [ __ ]
man he's 43 now you know
he's always a year older than me i'm
only 42. he kind of looked like brad
pitt huh that guy i mean oh so jealous
we all look like different people you
know
i look like attractive guys too it's
just different i'm more of a [ __ ]
that guy from my best friend's wedding
the gay guy okay so the thing about that
guy is
it's worse to live with regret than it
is to be rejected okay next video wow
also jimbo
emma hey chris how's it going love the
show keep it up love what you guys are
doing love tuning in so i'm just going
to cut straight to the chase here
i'm 22 i'm seeing a woman who's 44 and i
keep running into the same questions so
essentially people will ask
uh variants of is she a sugar mama and
she's not they'll ask
have she got any kids and she hasn't and
they'll ask is it weird and it's not and
there are a few other questions that are
sprinkled in there as well usually
but keep running into those over and
over again i was just wondering if you
had any ways to kind of give a shortcut
answer
and i also was wondering if you know she
is twice my age if you thought
there were any
maybe
practical implications of our situation
in the future that i should look out for
or if you guys have had any experience
with this yourselves
so uh yeah that's my question thanks for
listening to it and uh let me know what
you think a little bit well the
practical thing is she's going to die
way earlier way earlier than you yeah he
could get hit by a train or some [ __ ]
though true so you never trained in
australia but but i think that that
honestly those questions
then they'll never stop they will
never stop you just gotta learn to
breathe through that annoying [ __ ]
because that is not not gonna [ __ ]
stop sugar mama just look him right in
the eyes and say no
that's a [ __ ] rude ass question
anyway well the people are sure they're
funny they're idiots yeah they're idiots
oh really you think that's a joke
do you think they're being fun oh i
think probably mostly people it's
probably like oh shoot sugar mama that's
i think mostly probably stupid dude
uh people are happy though but um i i
was 30 and i dated a 51 year old
i yeah i uh have you yeah i mean that
what is it 21 years i don't think i've
ever that's a big that's exactly like
this guy yeah yeah yeah i i could i and
i was funny too because i invited her
out and she
came out i mean she was
smoking right like and she was like
smoking we were talking and she was like
you know um
you know i'm a bit older right and i was
like yeah and i didn't really know how
much older and then she told me she was
51
and we hung out a bunch of times she was
she was awesome and she's you know i
think that
i think some i mean it's cool you know
depending on how many trees are this guy
seems mature yeah like yeah you know
it's cool and it can work but it depends
on what the long play is right like i
mean if you want to have get married and
have kids it's probably not the move
right because we'd have to do it pretty
soon yeah you got it yeah you got to do
something you might i mean you might
yeah i actually
the age thing
that way like young men yeah older women
i think is sort of like
has like a weird cultural thing the way
people look at it it's like a source of
jokes more than anything else
and i think that if you're in a serious
relationship or you're really a lot
younger as the man and the woman is much
older i think you're kind of like in a
weird situation uh beyond the literal
unit of the two of you like people view
you yeah yeah yeah it's like such an
anomaly it's almost like humorous yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so i feel i kind of
feel your pain
but if it's a really serious
relationship you're going to learn to
breathe through those questions because
they're never going to [ __ ] stop uh
practical i don't know i don't i don't
think i would
give you any advice besides that which
is that if you really do
think long term that you you see it
working out with this woman not that you
should necessarily end it though that's
more on that right yeah to end it if she
doesn't have
if she sees those things in her future
that's true because she's so much i mean
butting up much more with the future
than you are i mean you're 20 [ __ ]
two you're so young wow but if you're
happy with this woman then [ __ ]
everything else yeah true yeah
this is hard to come by and if you find
a little piece of it grab it and hold on
to it forever completely john lennon
said that but completely right um
yeah i think that maybe uh
you know also too if you want to like
you can like be with her for a long time
and then she gets old and then either
she dies
and then you're like 40 or 50. and then
you got a whole nother life that you can
just kind of live so you're asking you
have two lives basically when you live
when you when you date someone older you
live two lives so you're asking him to
bake in her death to his plans for the
future well you have to
not really i mean she's 44. she's not
64.
she's young she's still like and he'll
be 44.
yes she will be and he'll be 44 that's
right yeah and then she'll be 70
something and he'll be 50 something and
then she'll die and then he'll get to
live a whole nother life with someone
else that's all i'm saying
so you're saying he should plan on that
for the future
her dying yeah wow okay well that's cold
[ __ ] it's not cold it's just true it's
reality and you know me dude i speak the
real but i'm saying you're planning for
another relationship after her no you
don't have to hold his eyes but no but
you don't [ __ ] do that you know you
just say like you know in your own head
you're like all good things come to an
end and then after that there's another
life where also there could be another
good thing and then that will come to an
end eventually but that would be when i
die how weird would it be for him to be
with this woman until she's until she
dies let's say in her mid 70s whatever
and then he's in his 50s
and then he turns around and dates
someone who's like 30. right that would
be the weirdest
right shock going from a 70 something
year old to a 30 year old yeah
i'm just thinking like that would be
imagine like the generation that's like
two generations yeah like the gap of
that going from gen x to millennial yeah
jesus that would be insane that would be
the wildest [ __ ] ever anyway [ __ ]
everybody [ __ ] them all for asking
stupid questions but they're not gonna
stop if you're in love with this woman
keep it up keep it going whatever
the age difference is only as big a deal
as you as you as you make it now
everyone else makes it right okay cool
next one
what's up guys uh my name is milo i am
24 years old from seattle washington
uh chris been following you since the
vine days true baby love you
matt i gotta introduce you through
congratulations but always loved it when
you were on and uh been loving the new
pod how are you going
uh thanks milo predicament for you so
as you can see we don't got a lot going
on up here sure yeah uh
i don't know if you can see the back but
it's on its way out
i think it started like junior senior
year college wow uh friends have been
giving me [ __ ] for it
i catch flack it's just like
i i think i'm ready just for it to stop
being a thing yeah you know so i'm
thinking about shaving it completely
you're gonna go ahead looking for your
advice
uh but one thing i do like having facial
hair yeah no chris i know it's it's one
of your a little bit
that much face hair can't be longer than
the head hair and uh yeah
i gotta say i kind of agree with that
wow
but we got limited options you're right
right right let me know what you think
uh what my next steps are and i'll see
you in the log cabin one day [ __ ] yeah
dude you will first first great
i think that uh you can have a little
bit of you can have
your your face hair could be longer than
your hair hair if you have no hair hair
and your face hair is like stubble like
yeah yeah that's okay yeah yeah but also
like the guy
has a good head yeah he's got a girl i
mean so
kylie so there's only one piece of
advice and it's this
full
agassi you go full
andre agassi the end and learn and learn
tennis or what what he could oh he went
oh because he had big hair and then had
yeah the big crazy [ __ ] hair that was
probably a [ __ ] wig and we all know
it and then he was like [ __ ] it all i'm
going mr clean
so now it's not going mr clean it's
going for [ __ ] action but you're
fortunate because he
has a good head like if i went bald yeah
trouble but you got to cut it dude you
got to cut it i mean what are you going
to do grow it out you look a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but he's basically there it's
like that's not even a one yeah yeah
that's not even a zero but it's like a
[ __ ]
like the shortest possible length of
hair is what he's got on his head but
also you could be like if if people are
making fun of me just say to them
like oh yeah you ain't got no hair you'd
be like yeah dude it's a good thing man
it's a good thing i don't have hair man
because if you'd if i did
i'd take your girl
you could also say oh no yeah oh you
want to make fun of me for [ __ ] have
for being bald you ever heard of a
little guy i like to call bruce willis
yeah right mm-hmm then they'd be like
didn't he have dementia and he'd be like
yeah but i'm not talking about the
dimension right like i'm talking about
10 years ago or jason statham
yeah work out so many dude also get
beefy as [ __ ] dude that would be awesome
he looks like he's kind of beefy right
yeah but he's 24 dude you might you know
what i mean you could be in 24 and
really not not do much yeah that's true
um
get [ __ ] take you know uh no don't be
a
you don't want to be too muscular with
the shaved head that's that's like your
like meat like a pack of [ __ ] meat
nobody wants that [ __ ] you got to be a
little bit like lean and mean with the
[ __ ] bald head you don't want to be
like mr [ __ ] muscles that's gross
dude yeah you're right you know you're
right i'm gonna be lean and mean you'll
be wiry
and [ __ ] sexy sinewy like yeah
this guy's got it in him for sure like
like like christian bale and a machinist
uh wow the machinist you know he wants
to he wants you no he needs to look at
brad pitt in the fight club that's she
kind of [ __ ] he wants yeah making this
in the christian
ex
balloon
uh yeah but get
do it
lost your mind get
go get a [ __ ]
razor blade and get
lost your mind or get shaving cream and
get a razor and go shh
robot malfunctioning
the guy from police academy
we're gonna go with the gut from police
academy
um all right cool next one
hey chris and matt my name is isabelle i
am coming to you guys out of the
philadelphia-ish area
uh i'm a huge fan and i am in need of
some advice okay so my boyfriend and i
have been together for like two and a
half years and we have been watching the
congratulations podcast together for a
majority of our relationship cute um he
got me into you chris and now i am
just a part of the cult what kind of
but anyway the advice i need is that my
boyfriend told me he doesn't want to
watch congratulations with me anymore he
wants to watch it alone every time oh um
he thinks it's funnier when he watches
it alone he i guess he appreciates it
more
um but i
love our weekly congratulations time and
i want to keep watching it with him yeah
so i know this isn't a big deal at all
it's kind of silly but i would like to
know how you guys would handle this
situation both chris and matt would like
both of your advice not just chris um
so yeah what would you guys do is it not
a big deal like i don't know what do i
do
uh thank you guys so much keep doing
what you're doing love you guys dude why
why why does he
he likes it better that's hilarious dude
like it's casino or something
don't bother me that's what i was gonna
say if it was like a dramatic film
or a dramatic tv show and like the
person you're with like likes to talk
through it i would get that but more
than that i would say
i would just say hey can we not talk to
it like i wouldn't you have to be alone
no also but it's also
silly and like you want to laugh with
somebody don't you this is hilarious
it's serious business for this guy well
i uh i think at first first and foremost
i'd be like why yeah why what the [ __ ]
that's so weird why and make him answer
and depending on what he says i guess
give him what he wants because he's
asking for it but that's
that's a [ __ ] weird thing
i don't even know what the [ __ ]
this is like it's good for you to get
more views yeah yeah because kristen
will like be like let's watch a tv show
and i'll be like [ __ ] yeah and i'll turn
it on it'd be like a great one like
boardwalk empire and we have [ __ ]
three episodes in and i'll look over and
she's just like either on tick tock or
not in the room anymore and then the
next night i'll be like let's watch
episode four and she's like nah we did
it last night and then i'm like you got
me hooked on a [ __ ] show
and now i'm watching it alone i got to
watch [ __ ] the whole season of
boardwalk empire yeah alone um and i
don't like that and that's a good i like
watching [ __ ] alone but i mean watching
it alone is fine if you start it alone
but if you started with somebody you
were like this was our thing so i get it
i get what she's saying yeah so you have
to watch all my podcasts in order
otherwise it doesn't make sense
uh
yeah i mean i i think it's just a really
weird request but if he insists if he
insists on it and if he has a good
reason which i don't know what that
reason could be but if you ask and he
gives you one
i guess give him
give him the space to watch it alone but
he's a [ __ ] weirdo start watching it
with another guy he'll come around well
that's true start watching it with
another guy i spread the cult and then
[ __ ] by the way you look great in
that hoodie you can get that hoodie at
chrisleya.com it says oops it's the oops
hoodie that's that bone one looks good
dude you're a fair skin and you wear
that bone colored hoodie
oh [ __ ] she looked real good sky's the
limit man i didn't know how that hoodie
looks so good with a nose ring too she
has a nose ring
yup dude that bone hoodie chrisley.com
speaking of which i'll be in dallas
coming up go to chrisley.com i'll be in
atlanta i'll be in denver but go to my
tour you know there's so many [ __ ]
tour dates crystalia.com albany i just
had it you ever been albany me yeah yeah
you have right why were you in albany uh
dated a girl who lived near or his
parents lived near really oh when you
were in college
no no oh really yeah oh right i remember
yeah um albany yeah have you ever been
to uh
lakeland florida i'll be there
nope okay
different places in florida never been
to lakeland florida
i've been to so many places bro yeah you
have been to a lot of places like places
that like i'll be in peoria nobody
should ever be there i'll be in rockford
illinois
i'm making that you're making up places
no i know it sounds like i am yeah um
cheyenne i've never been to cheyenne i'm
going to cheyenne you need when you go
to shine you need like a holster yeah i
know with like six shooters in them and
a big couple that's how i feel about
cheyenne too yeah you got to do it yeah
i was at the laugh factory last night
and there was a guy in the front row
with a [ __ ] cowboy hat on the on his
knee just chilling like he's like a
gentleman yeah it was gentlemanly yeah
and he said where are you from and he
said california
okay next where where in california i
mean probably up north for sure it gets
way down south near the border but it
was white it gets pretty rural in
california people think of it as like i
know i know i know coastal city [ __ ] is
no dude and it's so republican too if
you get out there and you don't even
know about it
the most like the majority of the space
in california yeah is covered by
red or republicans but way more people
uh obviously are right cities and
they're all [ __ ] liberal as [ __ ] i
already knew that okay well telling the
viewers in case they don't know mm-hmm
and listeners um yeah so anyway
oh i got uh oh uh subscribe to our
clip's channel too on lifeline oh okay
cool just saying and then also i got
some [ __ ] videos coming out where i'm
doing crowd work so subscribe to
okay so drunk okay yeah
do you want to do another one are we
done uh we could do one more right
all right cool
what up matt and chris the name sam
fellow new jerseyan chris you might
recognize me from king and this yeah i
remember her sorry i burned you uh i'm
sorry anyway
i'm kind of sending this in for two
reasons one being i never heard back
from king in this thing and it made me
kind of sad but why do i know who she is
and um basically i'm looking for
relationship advice somewhat on just
dating right now and encountering beta
males
every time i find a guy i like decently
he's [ __ ] beta as [ __ ] and i'm just
kind of over it like it's hard to be i
guess 25 and accomplished these days due
to society and [ __ ] inflation
but um yeah just kind of looking for
some advice on that still waiting for
theo to rescue me on his eagle let me
know what you guys think
hope to hear back from you love the show
thanks oh cutie um
i don't know what i know what a beta
male is obviously but it's not me that
could
that could mean a lot of things no i
wonder what she means she's running like
she meets a guy
then gets to know him a little bit
better and then like comes to understand
he's a beta that's what she's saying i
will say to this woman if you keep
running into the same problem yeah it
might be worth it
to look within yeah and i she seems like
a sweetheart and a [ __ ] cool chick
but i'm just saying i don't know you
maybe there's something you're doing to
attract these betas right maybe there's
something you're doing that you're
attracting these days or
maybe you're too alpha maybe you're too
much maybe you're the alpha maybe
everybody's dealing with the fact that
you're the alpha yeah in which case you
need a real [ __ ] alpha dude you need
a guy who wears sunglasses
all the time at night never has a shirt
on and just [ __ ] never or or maybe a
tank top at dinner but yeah he never has
his shirt on
and um
and just kind of [ __ ] you know
i think that also you might want to
consider
that
the beta thing might
however you're defining it might be
if you keep running into it and like
those are the guys that gravitate
towards you i'm not saying that you
should give up your ideal and like not
keep looking but maybe
for whatever reason that's happening
for like a if as a positive thing like
maybe you are the alpha and in a
relationship or supposed to be the alpha
yeah and maybe you should actually try
being the alpha in a relationship and
seeing what's up with [ __ ] beta dudes
because i don't know it keeps happening
you might as well give it a shot
yeah
they're they're out there and everybody
needs somebody but also every dude is a
beta really because the alpha male is
always
out there for everyone right like well
that's not no alpha and beta are types
though oh it's not like
it's not like actual like there's a
dominator and everyone gets dominated by
that one guy well one i mean it's not a
lot around any alphas so yeah it is uh
so it's you you're saying you're the
dominator
oh it is what it is huh when i walk into
a room no it's just like a tower i mean
and it's like it's a general type like
uh alpha and beta and she's running into
what she seems she sees as
was she saying when she gets to know
them she realizes they're like what's
going on now i don't know maybe she's
only meeting i don't know if she's only
meeting bettas and she's not giving
[ __ ] dudes enough of a chance yeah i
mean yeah and then the problem does lie
within but right if you're somebody that
figures out
uh oh wait this guy's actually beta also
the problem was within yourself so
basically the problem is within yourself
you're thinking too much about it then
you're either not thinking enough about
it or thinking too much about it you
also could be pulling the plug or
judging these guys too early yeah yeah
yeah because every dude's a [ __ ]
badass at something you know pretty much
yeah uh and so maybe you just gotta give
it more time to find that um and it
could be now in your head that it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen you're
looking for it maybe ease up a little
bit and let the alpha [ __ ] come to
you the alpha that you're looking for
however you would define it or quism you
know what would you do if four guys
tried to rob us
there you go right when you meet him
quiz him yeah and if a guy says
oh [ __ ]
i would run and leave you there right
beta right right if a guy says i'll kick
all their [ __ ] asses
right alpha but not the true alpha right
because you know what the true officer
says
i don't know what it what i don't care i
think the true alpha might say i do what
i want i would fight them but because
they're four of them i would probably
lose but i would i would rather me get
the brunt of the uh salt than you that's
probably what the the true
best possible alpha would say
he's he's realistic he's honest but also
would rather put himself on the line
physically to get hurt than you for
instead of you that's that's the right
thing right and that's what i would do
okay yeah well that's good so
we figured that out
okay so we figured that out for you
congratulations to uh everyone who we
figured things out for you know guys
that was a good episode of love lifeline
wasn't it that was a really fun one that
was good yeah um
and uh
chrisleya.com for tour um i will be i
said denver and all those other spots
you said them all all of them already so
we're not going to say that now all of
them subscribe to the channel austin
savannah raleigh jesus christ oakland
stockton
washington dc wichita okay well if you
have questions for us uh
click the link in the description below
or go to
watchlifeline.com and do it there uh we
love you thank you chris is showing off
his shoes and the life rip sauce and the
life rip socks uh
and yeah we'll see you next week thanks
guys
[Music]